you said that the Bro culture of
Entourage still exists you think that's
of course it still exists right to those
guys every night in Hollywood outside of
the Bro culture yeah 100 it still exists
oh are you referring to like how people
always go on and on about how
misogynistic the show was
do they do that
yes constantly and you're you're upset
by that oh I think it's like
that's what the show was it was about a
bunch of these a a different time B not
that different so what happens still now
I think I just always got sensitive
about it because I think people love to
hate on
things that are working
and so someone's always going to say
something and the truth is that you know
Doug Ellen was a genius and Doug Allen
simply wrote about
the that went on